let's get back to the phones and speak
to a few more people you can join the
discord through which we take phone
calls at davidpakman.com
discord it's a great system it really
really is
why don't we go next to dean from the
state of ohio dean you are on the air
hello hello hear me yes i can
oh um hi uh first time caller thank you
glad to talk to you david pleasure and
um i am a current college student in a
pl um a um basically a comp side class a
comparative politics and i was curious
when your opinion on parliamentary
democracies because right now in the u.s
we have kind of a
very strong gridlock in our senate
system and um i'm not obviously i prefer
presidential systems but you know if we
had a parliamentary democracy where we
could i guess effectively get more
things done do you think the us would be
a better or worse country for it it's
kind of a broad question my general
belief on this and i've i've talked
about it a little bit before is that i
think that a parliamentary system would
bring
actually many good things to the united
states where you would have um you know
a system where you have the leader of
the party with the greatest
representation in the legislature
becoming typically it would be like the
prime minister minister or the
chancellor rather than a directly
elected uh president um i i generally
think it would be an improvement for the
united states although i've had
some concerns that there's a lot of
really crazy extremists here and that
really horrible
uh parties which have no official
representation right now could end up
having some official representation and
that there's certainly a danger to that
um but you know it's a very hypothetical
it's it's merely an academic question
because the u.s is not going to change
to a parliamentary system anytime soon i
i'm not like trump where i go the u.s
will never
at no point soon right at no point soon
and so i think that we have to try to
improve things in other in other ways
of course
yeah but no i i like parliamentary
systems as a general principle
and um i guess there's a slight addendum
to that question we have a mix in the us
of a single member districts that we
elect and to represent people and then
we have a proportional system yes do you
think we would be better off if we went
to a hundred percent proportional i know
there's pros and cons of both but it
just seems like we have a senate that
disproportionately represents
republicans even though they have less
percentage overall in the united states
yeah the senate is fundamentally
anti-democratic i've talked about this
before it's not representative you have
um something like uh
the
senators representing i'm trying to get
the number right it's like 34 of the
population senators representing 34 of
the population
control half of the votes which is
fundamentally unrepresentative and
undemocratic again it's one of these
things where there's no way to deny that
that's the case and it's just not going
to change anytime soon and so i wonder
about
the
prudency of focusing on it i want to
make sure people understand this the
senate is fundamentally not democratic
and not representative
but
okay so then what do we do with that and
do we just focus on that and ignore
everything else that we could be working
on that doesn't seem prudent either
oh but but of course david um my
apologies i will try to come if i call
again next time to get a more um
pragmatic question i i was more of an
academic question i'm not criticizing it
i'm only making it like in other words
i'm saying you are 100 spot on about
these issues and i agree with you and i
talk about them as well
and i wonder what is the balance of like
activism capital that should be spent on
one thing versus the other when these
things seem very ingrained now the
counterpoint would be david if you don't
try to activate around these things
they're going to remain the way they are
and that's a good point too you know so
i don't know where our pragmatic versus
idealist balance should be
thank you so much david my pleasure all
right uh
extraordinary phone call there uh love
it
let's go
next
to
um michael
from berlin new jersey michael you're
next hi david how you doing
i'm doing all right you sound like
you're talking through a voice modulator
i know
a headset okay what's going on
i just wanted to uh i guess
uh explained experience at the polls
yesterday i uh
i vote i
worked as a poll worker
uh in new jersey and i just wanted to uh
explain my experience that it was
actually a great experience
it felt like i was really doing a
democratic
thing okay unfortunately um it didn't
work out the way i wanted it
wanted it to but but that's okay because
i felt like i actually
did my duty so um
are you curious were there poll workers
trying to electioneer in some way during
during their work
yeah we did actually have a problem they
were within the 100 foot zone
and people were complaining outside
but those were poll workers or these
were just people people trying to
campaign there
campaign absolutely okay okay okay did
you have any issues like on uh there was
this video there was a picture of some
guy all maggot out
working the polls you didn't have
anything like that
no no that's good yeah but thankfully
not yeah uh but we were in a
rural area in new jersey so uh
like close to the pine barrens so
maybe you would have that in the um like
in the big city maybe or or in the
suburban area okay
um but what i like
we were in teams like you couldn't just
be a poll worker and not have a like
i was in charge of bringing the votes
back into the central location
the town hall and i was teamed up with a
republican
and
it happened to be a woman actually i was
the only male in the whole group out of
12 i was going male
and
actually turned out to be a great thing
um
and she was such a
what was it she was definitely the
opposite of a low information person
like she was very special she's very
capable
and confident so i mean i guess i was
i'm
i'm thinking that negatively about
republicans so much
she i i just couldn't believe that she
was a republican that's how competent
and uh she just wanted to share that
that she was very
i don't know confident and i would
gladly work with her again no i'm
curious
why was it even coming up what people's
party affiliations were in other words
isn't it what is it because there's
supposed to be a split of democrats and
republicans
yes right if you return i was
responsible for returning
the ballots right and you can't do that
by yourself you have to have
a fair delegation so you have to have a
republican and a democrat got it got it
all right very good well it sounds like
it was a good experience i would
encourage more people to um to become
poll workers
yes i would do i would do the same thank
you beautiful all right michael from
berlin new jersey great to hear from you
uh a lot of people in fact uh in the
audience
emailed me and said david i was a poll
worker here i was a poll worker there uh
quite quite compelling stuff
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you first
hand every helix mattress comes with a
10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video